THE ATTACK KILLED 17 PEOPLE
BACK IN JANUARY OF 2015.
>> Sandra: MILITANT PALESTINIAN
GROUP HAMAS AND ISRAEL AGREEING
TO A COOLDOWN IN THE LATEST
ROUND OF HOSTILITIES AT THE
BOARD JS BECAUSE OF THE
CORONAVIRUS THROUGHOUT THE
HAMAS CONTROLLED GAZA STRIP.
THE GOVERNMENT HELPED BROKER
THE DEAL IN EXCHANGE FOR AN AID
PACKAGE.
WHAT ARE YOU HEARING FROM HAMAS
LEADERS ABOUT THIS AGREEMENT?
>> GOOD MORNING.
BASED ON THE HAMAS OFFICIALS
THAT WE’VE SPOKEN WITH, THEY
DESCRIBE THE GROUP AS
CAUTIOUSLY OPTIMISTIC ABOUT THE
NEW DEAL.
IT IS REMARKABLE THAT NEITHER
HAMAS OR ISRAEL SUFFERED ANY
FATALITIES DURING THE LATEST
ESCALATION OVER THE PAST MONTH
THAT INCLUDED ROCK ERT FIRE AND
IED BALLOONS OVER THE BORDER..
IT WILL REPORTEDLY INCLUDE A
FEW LARGER INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTS INCLUDING A GAS LINE
TO GAZA AS WELL AS MORE FUEL
FOR THE STRIP’S LARGEST POWER
PLANT, ONE OF THE KEY
NEGOTIATING POINTS FOR THE
FACTIONS THERE.
AS YOU NOTED CORONAVIRUS IS
SPREADING RAPIDLY IN GAZA IN
WHAT IS QUICKLY BECOMING A
NIGHTMARE SITUATION.
NEARLY TWO MILLION PEOPLE IN AN
AREA OF LAND 25 MILES LONG AND
SEVEN MILES WIDE.
AS PART OF THE DEAL GAZA’S 2
MILLION RESIDENTS WILL RECEIVE
CORONAVIRUS AID AND TESTING
CAPABILITIES.
HAMAS GAVE ISRAEL 30 DAYS TO
IMPLEMENT THE LARGER AGREEMENTS
OR FACE ANOTHER ROUND OF
ESCALATION.
I WANT TO UNDERSCORE IT IS A
TEMPORARY SOLUTION TO A LARGER
PROBLEM.
I’VE LOST TRACK OF HOW MANY
TIMES A CEASE-FIRE HAS BEEN
BROKERED IN GAZA JUST TO BE
BROKEN DAYS OR HOURS AFTER IT